Ways and Means Committee I find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic in accordance with the house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to the
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a revenue work
session please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporarily to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporarily Sly during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporar listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
Court website the notice for this
meeting complies with the house rules
RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS l.st do. Us in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us Christopher Shay and Brad Greenland
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call of
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to no law representative Bernstein
will you take the rooll thank you Mr
chair good morning everyone today is
February 18th it's 9:00 a.m. let's begin
the roll call um
attendance with Representative Patrick
abami Yeah here in my uh my home in
Strat New Hampshire my wife's in the
house representative Mary
Griffin representative
oy home my wife's in the house that's it
representative obber Forman Hudson with
ducet good morning uh at present I'm on
my mobile device in Salem and route to
my home office good morning your clerk
representative burin is in Nottingham in
his home office by himself
representative Elliot pres and my wife
is in uh the house somewhere
representative
janigian a home in Salem my wife and
daughter are somewhere in the house
representative herel Nunes good morning
representative uh I am home alone in
Pelham representative Baxter
representative
timbex representative spillsbury good
morning at home in Charles toown with my
wife and two children elsewhere in the
house good morning representative Paul
tutor I'm here alone in Northwood my
wife is in the house representative
Susan
omy here in Lebanon in my house alone
representative Richard Ames I'm here in
Jeffrey in my home office alone
representative Southworth here in do
alone representative
Malloy here at home in Greenland alone
representative shamberg representative
shamberg is here traveling back on
Interstate 89 representative Tucker here
uh in Randolph alone representative go
Marlo here in Swansea alone
representative lofman
representative Thomas lofman
representative gorg good morning I am
present and alone representative Mary
hackin Phillips morning I am present
from my office and conquered alone
representative Murphy good morning I'm
here in Hover my home office alone
representative major good morning here
in my home in
plasto my wife is in the
house Mr chair there are 21 members
okay because the snowstorm
there all right uh we have with us uh a
Governor's budget director Matthew ma
good morning Mr chairman Matthew Meo Meo
okay and he he will be addressing this
shortly after
um Chris Shay Our member from the
legislative budget office gets through
going through the
preliminaries this morning we're going
to do the go over the revenue
estimates and get information from the
budget uh from the governor's budget
director Matthew to determine
uh in
his Revenue
estimates what is current law and what
is not current law the part that's not
current law that's in his estimate so we
understand each other what our estimates
really mean and then also hopefully
he'll go over what's
the estimates are the affected by house
bill to so Chris do you want to go
through the documents that you provided
the committee here represent major so
last night um I sent out an email to the
members of the committee to that with
that email there was four
documents excuse me three documents um a
PDF and an Excel of a comparison
document a PDF and an Excel of the
worksheet and then the Lang House Bill 2
language that Matt provided me to share
with the committee about the
applicability dates for the various um
tax law changes and if I can I'd like to
share my screen so I can kind of walk
you through the comparison sheet as that
is and why it's different that would be
great uh if Jen or Brad could let me
so you should see an Excel page um
across the top it says house Ways and
Means and governor general fund
education trust fund estimates excuse
me so as you go across you're going to
see the FY 2021 plan and then you'll see
the governor's estimates for 21 22 23
and then you have the house Ways and
Means and I've populated what you've
discussed so far obviously that's
subject to change and then what the
differences are between what the
governor and the house um estimates will
be what you
see up on the governor's estimates on
the top half of that table so it's be
Row 4 through 20 that is current
law those estimates are based on current
law in fiscal year
21 the um
numbers are adjusted for the anomalous
Revenue that was collected in fiscal
year 21 that's going to go back to
fiscal year 20 so for instance if I
hover over the business taxes for fiscal
year 21 you'll see that the original
estimate was
8.25.18 point2 that goes back to fiscal
year um
2020 those numbers those those anomalous
numbers are in a table at the bottom of
this um
chart and so those are all adjusted up
above and then on lines 24 through
31 those are um Revenue
adjustments related to changes that the
governor's um suggesting in his house
bill too in house bill one and that's
what Matt will talk you through um you
know all the estimates for the governor
and then the
changes and then from here all these
Governor's numbers I just to the
worksheet if you if you're you recall I
had given you a worksheet um earlier
this week but I hadn't been able to
adjust the numbers yet because I didn't
um have the
detail so that now these numbers are
adjusted so if you go and look in the
worksheet you should find that these
three columns are now where the
governor's information
is um and then we did the same thing for
the highway
fund and for fishing game so there's
sheet and then
and I'll just stop share here and I'll
just pull up the worksheet so you can
just see where I was talking
[Music]
about so again on the
worksheet row 10 should now be all
adjusted with what you just saw in that
comparison
document row 17 would again be adjusted
with um any changes that
um removing you know the the uh the new
Revenue that's associated with changes
in in the budget so these numbers should
tie to the charts that you saw in that
comparison sheet that I showed
you so that's that's all those sheets
are it's a lot of information I gave you
an Excel file I gave you a PDF file um
um some people like to print them the
PDFs sometimes are a little bit easier
than the excels and some people like to
actually mark up the documents online so
that's why you have the
Excel um any any questions from the
point representative Brony yeah thank
you Chris um it would also be helpful if
you on a separate document just just
show us you want to speak up I'm sorry
uh Chris it would be helpful to see what
the actual uh revenues would were us
having to go through the math uh what
the actual reductions were or what the
governor thinks the reductions will be
through these new tax law changes the
whole
numbers but I can go back to to my work
worksheet from last week and to this one
and compare and start doing the math you
know what I mean so so are you asking
by it's only a handful of areas right
that have changed correct yep so let me
again so on this p on this sheet
here right you that sheet you've backed
out uh you youve you've equalized to
current law correct that's correct so
but on the bottom here that that's the
adjustments that are made oh they're
down the bottom there I'm sorry right so
for the meals and rooms for instance you
see it's a $19 million reduction in 22
and 23 I got it you've already done it
no you're good thank
you you're good thank you and again U
Matt will you know we'll talk you
through all of this and and um address
any questions that you have um and and
again he's invited here today to talk
revenues yeah and I can um you know as
as Matt gets going if he would like me
to screen share or if he wants to screen
share um the document that he needs that
that's fine as
well um but I think repent M has a
question but other than that I I think
we're almost ready for Matt and before
we go to represent yly when you look at
fy22 for the governor for the business
Governor's uh interpretation of current
law
yes yes and then you go down below the
uh the the business taxes will be um
adjusted by the Dr Auditors the BET
change for the threshold from to 250 the
rate change and then for the offsetting
BPT Revenue increase so four those four
lines would be netted against um the 824
to come up or we Ned against the 824 to
come up with that you go back up to the
FY 2022 8
24.9 our Revenue estimate under current
law may be
different than what the governor is this
is where our starting point is yep Y and
and some of these on the bottom here um
we won't fill it in until Ways and Means
and finance have looked at House Bill 2
and decided whether they're keeping some
of these changes and then we'll update
this document as we go through the
process so you can see that um for
instance if if finance and Ways and
Means and the legisl uh the house um
votes to pass the budget and and there's
certain things of these that are still
in there you'd see it carried over if
there's other adjustments for instance
if you disagree with the auditor
position and the amount of Revenue that
they would bring in we would show an
adjustment over here and if there's a
new tax or a new fee change that you
want to include whether it be up or down
we would add lines and you'd see that so
this would be a document that throughout
the process we would try to update um so
that the committee could look at that at
any point and know what's going
on okay represent y you had a
question not so much question other than
state that what Chris is presenting here
is more of a technical thing in in the
uh regarding where things are and how
they were set up uh that was all I do
however for
who for the Governor's um presentation
um regarding inflation so we'll get the
a head start on that one thank
you okay and you're going to hold it
right all right any further questions on
the
process saying
none
explain your Revenue estimates
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
members of the committee uh it's great
to be before you I'll be it virtually
and I'm sure this will be the first of
of many unique parts of this uh budget
process this year in light of Co um but
I think it's important to recognize that
you know this work is important as we
all know and it'll be challenging as we
all know but there certainly is a path
forward and I'm excited to kick that off
formally this morning uh discuss the
governor's Revenue
estimates I'm sure you all saw the
governor's budget presentation last week
and I'm sure many of you have also seen
the governor's remarks to house finance
yesterday uh and this budget is balanced
without any form of speculative Federal
money uh and we're excited to put
forward these Revenue estimates because
it does point to a strong economic
recovery not only in the business sector
but also in the hospitality sector
and I think the revenue estimates are
indicative of that you know we're we're
very confident that as the vaccine
contines to roll out um and we continue
to see people feel more comfortable to
go back out uh and participate in the
economy in the ways they did in the
before times uh New Hampshire is very
well positioned uh for a strong bium
ahead I'm sure many of you will have
questions on the tax cuts uh I'm more
than happy to discuss those and the
revenue
uh impacts associated with those uh I
would say that we've worked very closely
with the Department of Revenue
Administration in compiling these
estimates and one thing that you'll see
is that all of our estimates do fall
within the ranges that Dr has provided
uh both from a current law standpoint
and even also once you net out those tax
change
impacts um some of you may have
questions on macroeconomic indicators uh
C certainly happy to discuss some of
those potential action that we might see
out out of Washington DC which these
Revenue estimates do not reflect but
that is something that the committee
will need to consider um should
additional stimulus or investment in the
economy come from Washington that may
have a material impact on where State
revenues go but again that is not
included uh in anything that you have
before you today um from there I'll talk
a little bit about tax cuts I may have
some files to share that might be
helpful for the committee um but most of
all happy to take your questions and and
clear anything up that I might be able
to I believe a draft version of House
Bill two has been circulated to the
committee um obviously once that is
finalized I'm happy to have H further
conversations um but that should be a
good guide post for where we are
today we haven't seen that draft version
yet Matthew
okay um I don't know Chris if that's
something that um you might be able to
share with the committee I believe house
finance has seen it at this point and I
apologize if it hasn't made its way um
to Ways and Means just
yet so Matt we I shared the document
that you provided related to the
applicability but the full draft of
House Bill two that the governor
transmitted to um the finance committee
and then over to ol
um that version was released by the
chair of Finance to finance members and
we didn't have permission to go beyond
that at this
point that makes sense so right now it's
in drafting um with OSS um they're
they're working as quickly as they can
to get a a bill
drafted the the committee still needs to
um susp to allow for the introduction of
the bills I is my understanding as well
so once that's done and the drafting is
completed it will be released but in the
meantime I think they'll have to rely on
some of the information that you're
going to share Matt as well as um maybe
if they get something from represent wer
or other members of Finance but at this
point we didn't have permission to share
it be on the committee the finance
committee thank you Chris and I
appreciate that context um what the
committee should have are the relevant
tax Provisions that I was able to send
along those are um the the bulk of
everything that would be relevant to
Revenue conversation so that should give
us enough to go on for today
um before you go on uh there is a
question from represent
Ames yeah thank you um yeah Matt you
mentioned uh sorry to call you Matt I
probably should call you uh no worries
representative either is fine okay um
you mentioned when you started maybe
this was referring refering to the Hill
2 document that apparently we can't get
right now um to the governor's
presentation yesterday to finance and I
was going to ask if there was a written
version of that we were rather uh
preoccupied yesterday and uh so uh if
there is I'm sure that everybody on this
committee would would love to have that
and then uh regarding the Draft House
bill to I just I guess this is a
question more for the chair um is there
any way that we can get that because it
it does bear on our work I tax tax rates
are part of it but uh there's definitely
an overlap
taxes I will be contact with
representative wer right after this
meeting thank
you if I might represent major just to
make a comment if if you do get a copy
of the Draft House bill to that came
from the governor's office when House
Bill 2 is introduced it may look a lot
different there may be some cleanup
language there may be
reorganization of where sections are so
I just want to make the committee aware
of that so if you start working on
something and you're referencing draft
document when you get the real house
bill too it may not be in the same place
and there may be some some cleanup
language to make it fit the OS dra
drafting style understood and we put a
big draft right across it yep I just
felt I needed to say that that's all
yeah I think that's important to say but
it's exactly the same uh same uh
responsibility uh that the finance
committee members have with respect to a
draft document like this to treat it as
a
draft agreed and and that was mentioned
to them it's just we just wanted to make
sure that there's not confusion going
forward um typically you know it's
treated like an LSR you know it's an
individual's Bill and they um it's up to
them to release the language that's
associated with that um but usually you
mean you're moving much quicker with
house bill to than you have in past
years which is which is good and bad in
some ways if it could be drafted and
introduced you know ASAP that would be
the best course so there's no confusion
as you move forward about what sections
you're talking about and what the
impacts of those sections are so I'm
just just a cautionary note that's all
but I understand the committee needs and
would like to see language as they do
their work it's the same way with our
Revenue
estimates initial will be dropped and
they will continually to be changed
depending upon the economy up to the
point of Committee of conf have to make
the final vote on the budget
so all right you can continue Mr I've
got my hand up here I've had my hand up
represent Brony yeah um for Chris and
for Matt um you did provide us a summary
document of the of the hb2
changes uh as part of the packet that we
got uh maybe maybe that's a good spot to
start are there any surprises here I
mean they they are there other changes
that aren't captured here that we should
know about um and I'm assuming you're
going eventually go through this
document I don't know if Chris this is
Chris's document or yours
Matt rep brami that's a document that
Matt provided based on my request to him
that came from you that was the
applicability dates related to the tax
changes right right that Matt and his
presentation will'll be going over these
things okay all right yes and and thank
you Mr chairman and representative obami
that is a excerpt from house bill to as
uh it was submitted
um there may be other ancillary impacts
that occur in hb2 but those are the bulk
of what we would be would be relevant
for today's conversation relative to tax
rates um and the committee's work to
write estimates uh to close this bium
and into the next bium so uh I wouldn't
say that it is 100% but it's the vast
majority um of what those changes look
like so was just saying the smaller
tweak TW there's other potentially other
tweaks in the the current law okay yes
but not anything that would impact um
the tax rates that we would need to
estimate on and I think one example
would be uh the tobacco settlement um
allocation to the education trust fund
for example in current law it's stated
affirmatively at 40 million these
Revenue estimates look that the amount
will be below 40 million so there's a
clarifying Vision that's that will be
introduced in
hb2 um to address that things of that
nature right things that wouldn't impact
the committee's ability to make
estimates on uh those dollar amounts
okay thank
you okay well I don't way to let uh
Matthew make his
presentation thank you Mr chairman um
and just to continue what I would say is
when and even looking back at this
committee's work a few short months ago
in 's early days and where we didn't
know where things were going the
shortfall that we're projecting at this
point is now below $50 million and if
you look at the Surplus statement that's
included in the executive summary
booklet uh we're thinking that the rainy
day fund will be uh very healthy even
once we have covered the shortfall from
this bium that gives us a very strong
base to make our estimates from uh even
under current law and what I would say
as far as as this process this was a
consultative process again working
closely with Dr working closely with
commissioners of different agencies uh
to develop these Revenue estimates based
on actuals for 2020 actuals for the
first six months of fiscal year
2021 and then do monthly estimates for
the remaining months of this bium before
applying a growth factor for
fy22 and then a similar process for FY
23 so it's a very granular process where
we attempted to identify where taxes
would change on the short-term basis to
create a base that we could estimate on
for the much greater uncertainty in
fiscal 22 and fiscal
23 and what I'll share with the
committee here um is a summary of the
taxes
where our estimates fall compared to
those Dr ranges and I apologize that
maybe is a little bit smaller um than
what I had hoped to have for you today
um and Matthew uh what you show on the
screen will be be provided a copy yes
I'm happy to email this after the
conclusion of today's work session for
the
committee um but what you see here uh in
the top what's shaded in that black box
are all taxes aggregated and it shows
where the agency provided a range all of
those compounded together shows where
the governor's Revenue estimates in hb1
under current law where we fall in that
range you can see that overall we're
very much in the thickest part of that
band um very close to the median other
tax estimates such as meals and rooms or
the real estate transfer tax uh were
very bullish compared to the agency
projections of where those taxes will
close
fy21 uh which gives us a higher base to
estimate from for 22 and
23 now what this chart doesn't show is
how wide those ranges are right and if
you look um down below at the range say
for business taxes you're going from 800
million to 824 million in fy21 is that
banned which is much wider than say uh
something like the real estate transfer
tax where the entirety of this band is
only about $10
million um so there are some some
graphical challenges that I do do want
to point out for the committee um but I
do think this is a a helpful visual way
to show where the governor's estimates
are under current law um compared to the
range that the agency has provided and
again just underscoring that everything
that we've put forward does fall within
those ranges and I'm happy to answer
questions and and have any type of
debate um on how bullish or bearish we
should be under that current law
forecast what I will say is that these
Revenue estimates were compiled based on
in most cases actual data through
December
for business taxes meals and rooms
interest and dividends we were able to
compare those amounts to January actuals
that were published in the monthly
Revenue
Focus um so some taxes and you'll see
this in the the Excel spreadsheet that
Chris Shay has put
together some of those estimates uh you
have more updated data than we do um in
some of those instances and I'm happy to
talk through that as well but the
overarching point is that under current
law these estimates are are well within
range um and I'm happy to talk more
about the process that we went through
to identify these specific uh dollar
amounts the other thing that I want to
show with the committee and I think this
will be helpful as well would be
the uh tax change
document um that Chris has provided you
with as well and this would be the
changes to current tax law relative to
the meals and rentals tax the business
Enterprise tax and the interest in
dividends
tax so I'll start with meals and rentals
is I think this one might be the most
straightforward to explain this budget
proposes a reduction from 9% to8 and a
half% effective for taxable periods
beginning on or after OCT October 1st
2021 so essentially in the second
quarter of the first fiscal year of
bium um to allow for a phase in for
those entities to uh be made aware of
the change in tax law and also update
any of their uh collection or remittance
procedures uh to
Dr um the second and I guess if there
are any questions on um just the the
wording or the impact
the meals and rentals tax happy to take
a pause here before going on to the
business Enterprise tax representative
brne yeah this is a minor thing but I'm
looking at uh F the 88 cents to a dollar
and that still stays at nine cents that
seems like kind of well shouldn't that
be eight and a half as
well that is a the DAT is a fair point
um I don't know I know there's a lot of
Legacy behind Behind these amounts under
a
dollar um I don't know if the committee
would want to revisit this because I
don't know that these have been updated
in quite some time um but we certainly
wouldn't have any opposition to reducing
um uh letter F or sub paragraph F uh to
eight and a half
cents it just didn't seem logical that's
all um I mean eight and a half is the
eight and a half at at Dollar and above
um I'm having I'm not having heartburn
over it but it just seems it's a little
anomalous a little bit
representative
represent represent a you have your hand
up I did have my hand up but I was going
to make the same point which is
unimportant that it should be eight and
a half cents and half so just agree with
representative abami is a very minor
Point represent Aly thank you on those
are in there for a purchase of under 10
cents there is no half cent available
anywhere you can't put it on a check you
can't put it uh you can't bring out a
anymore thank you representative and
that could very well be why Dr opted to
not adjust sub paragraph F when we ask
them to compile language for these tax
changes as is our practice um so whether
that should be eight or nine um again I
don't know that we have a strong
preference um one way or the other on
that particular aspect of this
change
represent if there's any uh purchase
under 10 cents left in the world
anyway that was a
followup rep your yeah I was just going
to say but we do calculate things in
tenths of a scent fuel for one uh and
that's still a valid unit of measure
no more questions uh go ahead
Matthew Mr chairman I think
representative spillsbury might have a
question oh represent spb I didn't I
thought I saw your hand up once but
thank you I just I just want to clarify
this because I think it got mudded again
and I have to agree with representative
Aly the only point of little a through
little uh f is to pin down what occurs
when a purchase is under $1
dollar G is the
action so you can't split a penny if
you're trying to charge somebody at a
England and again I would question
whether or not these Legacy sections are
still essential to the law I think
that's something for the legislature to
aine on um but I agree that a it would
not change the fiscal impact whether
this was eight or nine for purchases
between 88 cents and a dollar
um and the intent is that eight and a
half would be the amount um for
purchases under this tax um and
purchases below a dollar however the
committee would like to address that um
there there is not a strong opinion um
from us on that particular Point okay I
on okay excellent and thank you Mr
chairman um moving down to the business
Enterprise
taxs um there are two components in
bet one of which is the threshold
increase uh and of course there are two
ways that a business can qualify or or
meet the threshold to pay bet one of
which is their gross receipts the other
is their Enterprise uh tax value base or
base value I
apologize this budget would propose
$250,000 in current law they are set at
$100,000 for Enterprise uh base
value based on cost of inflation that
has since risen to
$1,000 this proposal increases that to
250,000 for gross receipts in current
law that is established at
200,000 again with those cost of or
those Consumer Price Index adjustments
that the department has the discretion
to make that is increased to
$222,000 and again this budget proposal
would raise that to
$250,000 as well um and I apologize that
I did not copy section 94 uh into this
document which shows those changes but
again it's just changing those threshold
amounts for the rate reduction
this budget proposes reducing the BET
rate for all periods ending on or after
December 31st
2022 by five basis points from
0.55 notably this budget does not make
any changes to the business profits tax
I know there are several bills in the
legislature that propose to make
adjustments to both of these taxes and I
know historically these taxes have been
adjusted in unison the rationale that
we're using um to reduce bet but not the
business profits tax is that we know the
be is the tax that small businesses pay
the tax that Mom and Pop shops on Main
Street pay and when we think about
accelerating this economic recovery we
wanted to make sure that businesses here
in New hampsh
that need the most relief have that
available to them um which explains the
reduction in bet as opposed to the
business profits tax and happy to take
any questions on this proposed change
questions representa me thank you Mr
chairman on do you have any idea from Dr
yet I guess I don't know if we're seeing
them this after I hope we are on about
how many on what percentage of the small
B of the businesses paying the business
Enterprise tax would drop out we had
constitutional challenges as you
probably know uh about this on before
the BET came in that the BPT payers were
paying almost all of the tax and there
weren't very many of them and therefore
um the um Supreme Court should rule
against the the
BPT and um I've always worried when we
increase the threshold about whether
we're getting to a point where we're
Beyond um where we're challengeable
again thank you for that question
representative um and I I am aware of
the Constitutional Provisions regarding
um the tax base and ultimately how broad
of a base that is um uh this has not
explicitly been evaluated for a
constitutional um Pro uh analysis I'm
happy to bring that back um and and
report back to the committee on if we do
have any concerns there uh based on dr's
initial
analysis approximately 30,000
businesses would fall within that
threshold
um raising the Enterprise based value
from again
$111,000 today to
$250,000 through this change um but let
me confer with them as far as the total
number of payers that still remain um
and if they do have any concerns there U
so I appreciate the question and I'm
happy to follow back
up could I follow up just briefly follow
up thank you on when we looked at this
before I was comparing it at any rate
with the uh
percentage of payers on that the number
of payers in the business Enterprise tax
versus the BPT the the ratio that was
established by the people who put in the
BET um just to use it as a rule of thumb
I have no idea whether that's a correct
way to do it or not
okay I will I will take a look at that
representative and try to use that as a
proxy um for you and I'm happy to
connect offline as well um based on the
work you've already done in this
while I have a question for you Matthew
what
happens if House Bill 10 which reduces
BET passes as
is how would you adjust your
budget well ultimately I would I would
strongly encourage the legislature to do
any tax changes through House Bill 2 um
as opposed to a standalone um so my hope
is that those Provisions would be
incorporated into the budget um and
from there I believe it's the
legislator's affirmative decision on as
to whether or not to reduce the business
profits tax um I think there are are
strong reasons on both sides when it
comes to how businesses pay taxes in the
state um and again this budget does not
propose a reduction to the business
profits tax um but of course the
governor uh does support that he has
signed that previously um and that was
something that was introduced uh in his
uh the budget for the current bium so
our position has not changed um but when
we looked at where we can deploy tax
relief to make sure it does span the
entire economy we wanted to look to
other taxes as well which is why you see
the the separate reductions in rooms and
meals um and increasing the BET
threshold um to make sure that those
small businesses the ones that have been
hit hardest by the economic uh impacts
of the pandemic
uh see the relief directed at them um
and provide the greatest opportunity to
enhance that economic recovery um I
think as as many of us
know and I'm sure all of you know um the
economic recovery uh for the largest
Fortune 500 companies has been uh fairly
robust I think we've seen that not only
through the business profits tax
payments but also um the the overall
market performance
um so that we saw this as an opportunity
to make sure that tax relief is directed
uh where it's most
Ames thank you um so just back to the
BET threshold change um I think you said
that you had meant to supply but uh uh
you will if we ask for it the uh section
94 changes you walked us through them
verbally but it would be helpful to have
that um and then
um if perhaps you said this or perhaps
you going to come to this but I'd like
to know exactly how you calculated the
revenue in impact of the
threshold of these changes in the
thresholds certainly and I'm actually
just going to copy um this language into
this word document and I will share it
with the committee at the conclusion of
this as well um so one second if this
works and I'll have this reformatted um
but as you can see the changes in
current law compared to what we're
proposing through this budget um and
then we still retain that Consumer Price
Index uh adjustment as well okay that's
helpful thank you so I'll I'll clean
this up make sure you have the most
updated version and I do apologize that
this wasn't included the initial version
I sent
over um to the second part of your
question representative regarding the uh
impact of these tax
changes um so we asked the Department of
Revenue Administration to conduct a
fiscal analysis for a variety of tax
options some that were more aggressive
others that were less aggressive um in a
variety of
areas uh they did pull together that
static fiscal analysis based on
um the most recently completed fiscal
year uh for that um for that individual
tax and uh what you'll see at the bottom
section of that uh worksheet that cret
has put together and provided to the
committee um you'll see that there are
three different aspects of how this
reduction to the business Enterprise ta
tax would carry through on the Surplus
statement um and Chris I don't know if
we can share that once more just to talk
through that and then I'll come back to
the document that I was working
off do you want me to share the
comparison sheet Matt if you could that
you so you should see it
now yes you want to go
so the the gov proposed changes to
current law so we're looking at lines
2728 and 29 are the three that are all
directly tied to the proposal to reduce
the bet uh rate and increase the
threshold and I'll walk through these
one by
one um so by increasing the threshold we
would see
approximately an annual impact of $2.3
million each year as a result of
business businesses no longer needing to
file um or qualified to file for the
bet uh so you see that reduction in each
year when we decrease the rate from 6 to
0.55 we do see a larger impact in FY
23 as opposed to
fy22 and that's primarily due to how tax
years overlap with fiscal years uh and I
would defer to dra to explain um the
finer details of that but essentially we
would see more businesses have a taxable
period um that is applicable to this
lower rate um when they file their
quarterly estimates in FY 23 so even
though we're taking no further action to
reduce the rate in FY 223 that impact is
more
pronounced the third thing and this is
um something that again I'm sure the
committee is aware of but was
interesting to
consider when Dr did provide this
analysis for the governor's office um is
that because bet is held as a credit
against the business profits
tax we would see offsetting Revenue
increases in the BPT as a result of this
action and when a business files this
tax essentially they calculate their BPT
obligation and then reduce that amount
by what their bet obligation is um and
you see those cmeasured
impacts um in row 29 and again more
pronounced in the second year of the
bium even though we're not taking any
23 and happy to take any questions on
that point and I I hope that answered
question representative Asim I know
that's what what started us down this
path so I hope that helps I need to
raise my
hand you all
start no wait a
minute um yeah no I've got I do have a
followup question sorry just struggling
with this
um yeah the uh that's that's helpful um
I would like to see and I imagine we'll
get it from Dr the uh detail on how
that loss of $2.3 million attributable
to the threshold increase was uh was
calculated um but uh going beyond
that my my follow-up question is whether
you you must have done this uh
calculated um impacts going forward from
FY 23 and this is a question that uh
relates not just to these tax changes
because the impact will be different
just as you noted the FY 23 impact is
different from the
fy22 impact it all relates to when
taxpayers pay their taxes um and when
they do their estimates and so forth um
but uh it the the uh largest impact uh
that
um that we should have information and
going forward Beyond the 2-year bium is
the in DX where you've got a phase out
uh number
6.3 in FY 23 but you know perfectly
obviously it's a hugely different number
um as you go forward from there so I my
question is about impact Beyond this uh
twoyear
window right can we that until
get sure
but what about
business uh so for the business
Enterprise tax um I do have information
that I can provide to the committee um
that does come from Dr uh that does
detail those annual impacts based on
these
changes um and I'm I'm happy to provide
that um
essentially the the full impact of this
tax change is felt beginning in fiscal
2024 and forward the vast majority of
that impact is felt in FY
23 as
85% um
of the percent applicable to the given
tax year would be captured in FY 23 um
but there would be a smaller um Step
Up in FY 24 and that would be um the
continual impact absent future changes
to this tax
rate okay that's helpful um and I I'd
love to see that I'm sure all members
would um and I think before anyone else
says it I'll say it that uh I I
understand and I'm sure everyone else
understands that these are static uh
these are based on a static analysis and
uh you know there's all sorts of
variables that one could throw in and uh
guesses but this is just a static
analysis that is correct representative
um and that is something that I think we
all will consider as we go through this
process um but based on the the static
fiscal impact these are are the this is
the analysis that was put forward um and
there may be other variables that the
committee may choose to add in um as
they would with any other decision that
they
make and your analysis based upon
that coming out of
the the pen mic so that economy is going
industry that that is correct Mr
chairman and uh specific to meals and
rooms we see a very robust recovery um
beginning this summer we think there is
a tremendous amount of pent up demand we
think that people that maybe visited New
Hampshire for the first time during the
pandemic um tend we tend to think they
enjoyed their time here we know a lot of
them have stayed permanently um so we do
expect people to change their habits
coming out of Co and and we think that
has a positive impact for the economy uh
overall anything that we can do to
attract more people to come and stay or
visit or recreate in New Hampshire um
given our very vibrant tourism economy
certainly helps the state coffers the
second with the
BET as representative am said this is a
and and two 2023 isn't that far
out but 2023 can still be affected quite
a bit by what happens through covid this
year that is certainly true
representative and I will also say from
a methology standpoint um we
extrapolated based on our base for fy2
21 for the estimates in the two years of
the next bium um so any increase that we
see for the fy21 base would Cascade
through this the multiple fiscal years
um by virtue of how we conducted the
analysis did you have any input from
Health and Human Services relative to uh
how the pandemic is going to be
handled yes so we did have uh
representatives from DH HS as part of
the informal Revenue commission that we
assembled um to vet these numbers um and
you know I think there was agreement
that there was a tremendous amount of
uncertainty for where we close fy21 and
where we see ourselves in fy22 but we
did feel confident that the underlying
assumptions were valid um and the other
thing that I would say is if anything
fiscal year 21 continues to outperform
uh where we expected it to be in light
of Co and just to to pinpoint one
example um in February we expected all
Dr taxes to be down 7% compared to plan
in aggregate um and based on the latest
numbers uh from Dr it sounds as though
that is going to be a very conservative
estimate um and very likely that the
state will exceed plan uh for the month
of February um so again I think
that it's one of those things that is
difficult the committee certainly has
the luxury of more time and more
economic data uh especially in the
months ahead and of course even more so
on the Senate side but we feel
comfortable that this is our best foot
forward that we can um you know take
that first step from the governor's
point of view um and if anything these
Revenue estimates may continue to
improve as the committee receives
additional data
ask you one more question um what would
be the result of FY three on the bet
changes if you use the
conditions we did not specifically model
um a pandemic we didn't do any modeling
specific to the pandemic um but we see
data much in the same way that you do um
where Dr provides an estimate um and
then we conduct an analysis of if that
estimate is is too bullish or too
bearish or right on the money um and
what I would say if we point back to
that uh graph that I showed earlier
business taxes under current law are
well below the 50th percentile compared
to what that range provided by Dr is so
if anything business taxes could be
revised upward compared to where they
hb1 okay represent
El thank you on I have a number of
questions but I think on the discussion
has has taken care of one of them but
specifically for um for the
B um business tax are you based which
year on was Dr basing this on that you
took is a static analysis from 18 or 19
20 uh this
analysis was based on fiscal year 20
cash basis Revenue
plus the anomalous receivables that
fy20 okay so it is the and for the
threshold increase the department used
tax year 18 to calculate uh their fiscal
analysis that we reviewed for
that so the
threshold was
18 yes and again I I am happy to provide
the the underlying methodology of the
tax proposals that we did move forward
with um from Dr after this meeting um
there are separate analyses in here that
we did not move forward with that I
would just want to um review before um
sending this
over thank you I think it it really does
make a difference which year we're
looking at um but uh and then also think
this is more for finance than for us but
we're supposed to look at the split on
have you looked at what effect the
changing on proportions of bet and and
BPT are going to do to to the revenue
going into the general fund and the
ETF yes that is something that we did
consider um based on current law and
there's no proposal to deviate from
current law into how those allocations
occur um for bet the analysis is the
revenue raised by uh half a percentage
Point divided by the current rate uh so
right now it is um 0.5 divided by 6 is
that calculation the department goes
through and for fiscal year
23 uh we have updated that to account
for the uh different rate that would be
in effect at that time it's my
understanding the calculation does use
uh data that is one year in a rear so
that impact would only be felt in fiscal
23 um but if I have misstated that I
would encourage uh the department to
correct me um if any of that is is not
quite 100%
accurate I could have a quick followup
on
I do not believe that the statutory
language has uh is uh adequate for all
of the changes that have been made to
the reductions in the BET and the BPT in
the last six eight years whatever it is
now um that it was based on the original
tax
rates Thank
You by represent Bernstein Bron
representative
tuer you like to have my question now
yes yes I'm uh represent Coos 5 so I'm
very involved in thinking about
Hospitality as everyone else is in Coos
5 and across Coos so I'm very interested
in
how uh the group came up with 8.5 in the
meals and
rentals rather than the status quo or
we'll say 8% could you discuss a little
bit uh how you landed on
8.5 sure so we we did conduct analysis
at at varying levels um of reductions or
the status quo uh for meals and rent
meals and rooms
tax um I don't know that there was any
magic number behind 8.5
other than that we felt it was a sizable
reduction that would have impacts and
would signal to uh both New Hampshire
residents and also out of state visitors
that New Hampshire is doing everything
it can to help small businesses
including
restaurants um and we see this as an
opportunity
to um reduce U that tax rate uh in a way
that will help stimulate economic
activity and help Drive the recover
recovery
forward um but I don't believe that
we're married to 8.5 as opposed to 8%
other than to say we believe a reduction
is the right policy for the state to
pursue uh and there are benefits um that
will Cascade throughout the economy by
taking that
action thank you represent burnson thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question Matt my question regards the
increase in the threat threshold of the
bet you mentioned well it shows there'll
be a revenue reduction of 2.3 million if
we divide that by the 30,000 small
businesses affected by this we get $77
per
business
um can you speak to how 250,000 as a
threshold is The Sweet Spot what would
happen if that number went up to 300,000
or went down to 200,000 how'd you land
that
so we did look at a number of different
factors and a number of different
proposals uh that Dr was asked to
consider uh ranging from say 150,000 to
250,000 um there were commerate tax rate
or um sorry tax revenue impacts at those
different levels spanning from 1.5
million each year at
150,000 um it's the number you see there
before you would 2.3 each year for
250,000 um and ultimately what I think
the the benefit here is if that you're a
small business maybe you're a business
that's just getting started um and
you're falling within that threshold
between 100,000 and
250,000 um there is benefit to reducing
some of that administrative overhead
especially for businesses that are just
getting started um or maybe it's an
entrepreneur who had event
and uh Co had adverse impacts maybe they
had to shift away from that and pivot to
where they saw new opportunity we want
to make this tax um less burdensome on
those small entities and allow that type
of innovation uh and Foster additional
opportunity for small business owners
and and that's why we chose to increase
it um based on representative aly's
comments I I do want to just go back and
look at any that has been you know put
on paper regarding um whether or not the
base is Broad enough to satisfy
constitutional Provisions um so I will
follow up with the committee on that I
don't know if I'll have a definitive
answer but at least to say that we've
considered it at this point um but I I
hope that answers your question
representative you did and thank
you representative
bronley um I do have some questions on
the several of the lines but I think uh
uh we should allow uh um the
finalization of the presentation on the
interest and dividends tax reduction
first and then we can uh then I'll raise
my hand again and ask additional
question so can he proceed with his to
finish his uh discussion of the of that
other uh sheet that had the summary of
the the three tax reductions that were
in play we haven't talked about the
interest in dividends tax reduction yet
oh we're still on the bet so you want me
to ask my bet questions now
I mean these are more General nothing to
do with tax reduction okay uh so do you
want me to hold on that or do you want
my my be questions now go ahead so when
you when you when you did your your your
estimating going out uh forget about the
taxed you know the be uh T reduction and
all you had to do some
estimating we had two two changes in
play right now Market base
sourcing and then single sales factors
on the books
um we we feel it's very hard to predict
the impact of especially the single
sales Factor um in the out years here on
this budget um can you can you tell us
how you handled that I mean we we
obviously would like to slow that change
down on on on house ways and means but
assuming it goes
through uh and not not changed then that
there'll be an impact especially out on
on
2023 um even the
Bia uh their members are split on
whether this is going to be a good thing
or a bad thing um so how how did you
weigh both Market based sourcing into
this and single sales factor into your
estimates um which seem pretty robust
going out I'm pretty bullish on the
business taxes be honest on the business
Revenue I think businesses especially
our our most of the BPT is from the big
larger companies I understand so but but
we're not sure what the impact is going
to be with single sales Factor obviously
I'm assuming the government feels a
little more bullish about it than we do
can you explain
that certainly representative and I
agree that I think when you look at
where the business taxes fall on that
range that I showed earlier um there may
be room uh
for for Ways and Means to to expand upon
that as they see more economic data come
in um what I can say is the governor's
budget did not propose any changes um to
either single sales factor or
market-based
sourcing um and that when we were
working with the Department of Revenue
information they have a lot of the same
question and uncertainty of exactly
where those impacts will be um so I I
don't want to speak too much only to say
that this is is a going to be a robust
change and um until we see that first
bits of data come in um that's when we
know but I do think that these estimates
are conservative to the point where even
if um those impacts turned out to be
adverse for one reason or another um
business tax performance likely to your
point uh will be more bullish uh over
these next two years and as far as what
we estimate out uh for business
taxes uh was a modest
2.25% increase uh from the fy21 base and
then a 5% increase to the FY
23 um based on in compounding on that
fy22 estimate um so again we see
opportunity to grow um for these
business taxes especially with the
reductions that we're making um to the
tax rate so I I appreciate those
comments and I'm happy to Circle back
either offline or in more detail at a
later date right on single sales factor
in market-based sourcing just a follow
up then so so the governor the
governor's office you you and the
governor are pretty forget about covid
and all
that just on on single sales Factor I'm
assuming that the governor feels that
this is going to be more of a positive
than a
negative that's yes that's certain
uh why we had supported uh the policy um
to put it on the books uh again I I
think the the fiscal analysis is
something um that I know there's debate
on uh I know Co is certainly something
that that will weigh into the
committee's decision but our position
hasn't changed uh and again there are no
proposed changes in the budget that
would either delay or undo those
changes okay thank
you representative elme thank you Mr
chair on just a followup to that is
there any evidence anywhere whatsoever
that a small elderly State on with a lot
of manufacturing that exports just about
everything to sales in other states on
is going to gain from single sales
Factor when our biggest tax
is
on is about what is it 80 90% of it
companies uh so representative I
appreciate the question um I would
appreciate a chance to Circle back with
you on on that particular Point yeah I
wish you'd Circle back with the whole
committee okay I I'm happy to do that um
but let me just I haven't uh specific
Ally pulled that data for this morning's
conversation I know it's something the
committee is continuing to work through
um but but happy to to bring that back
uh to the
committee the committee is as a
this further questions on the
BET tax
changes all right now we can go to the
IND
CH excellent and uh Chris if you could
stop sharing your screen um I guess it
won't allow me to do that until you go
ahead thank you so much
um for the interest in dividends tax
what and I know there are several
proposals in the legislature as well
that might use different mechanisms to
get to essentially the same spot um this
tax we propose to
use a 5-year phase out uh at a linear
Glide path uh so that the tax is
eliminated at the end of
2026 or for taxable periods ending
December 31st
2026 um notably this tax change does not
begin in the first year of the
bium um this would only impact the
second year of the next bium uh going
from five down uh to 4%
the thinking is that given the
uncertainty surrounding Co we wanted to
make sure that the legislature had a
window of opportunity that should things
uh either not recover as fast um to to
have that opportunity to see a Year's
data past covid um before this
particular tax impact would take effect
um obviously from a policy standpoint we
fundamentally believe it's the right
thing to do uh New Hampshire is proud to
be an income taxfree State uh it's part
of our core New Hampshire Advantage uh
and by phasing this tax out we can
remove the aster U of income taxfree and
you know say that affirmatively the way
other states can that there's no tax on
income whether it be your paycheck your
interest or dividends that you might
receive and we know this tax
disproportionately impacts seniors um
that are living on fixed incomes and may
be either uh wholly or mostly reliant on
these uh sources of income uh to sustain
their retirement uh and again to the
extent that this encourages more people
to stay in New Hampshire or relocate to
New Hampshire you see other positive
economic impacts whether it be through
rooms and meals or other taxes that we
might see um both at the state and local
level um and again from a from policy
stand point we fundamentally believe
that that now is the opportunity to take
this step uh it's something that's been
debated for a long time right I think uh
in some cases maybe even the past 50
years this has been an ongoing
conversation uh and we're very excited
to be able to put this into house bill
too uh and happy to answer any questions
on the interest and dividends
tax well thank you uh represent
Ames thank you um just uh it looks is
this a mistake or am I somehow not
reading it correctly you uh you
have the annual tax rate at 5% for all
taxable periods ending onor before
December 31 oh I get it h after forget
it I'm all
set okay um what would it look like in
that it only affects us in
20 wait a
minut 23 what would
[Music]
20 I do have a question I guess so Roman
1 eight says that the tax rate will be
5% for a tax FL period end I'm going to
shorten this ending on December 31
2023 Roman 2 says that the tax rate
shall be at 4% for a taxable period
ending on December 31
2023 so I'm not sure you got this right
that is a a good point it does appear
that tax periods ending specifically on
the 31st of December
would be captured uh in both of those
statements this is again a product of
working with draft legislation that will
be cleaned up by legislative services
but I can reiterate the intent uh is for
this tax to expire at the end of 2026 as
you see Roman five and what's the first
4% uh I I would defer to the the
specific language that will be published
in hp2
but in order for this tax to sunset at
the end of 2026 you would see taxable
periods ending after December
2023 right so essentially ending on in
Roman one should I believe and again I'm
not uh a legislative drafter of this
particular language but um should not be
inclusive of December 31st 2023 in Roman
1 um but I don't know if Chris I see he
has his hand up and and maybe the LBA
has already um reviewed this with OS
Chris so Matt's um kind of hitting the
nail on the head you know as as OS goes
through the language they'll Identify
some of these types of issues and then
they would come back and talk with um
the governor's office or our office to
help clarify you know what the intent is
so again this is just another one of
those um concerns that we have that when
the dra language might be used by the
committee you may end up getting more
confused than you would if you have the
actual house buillt two to look
at but yes we would try to get it
cleaned up with OS and working with the
governor's office to make sure that it
was okay
thank you Mr
chairman I I'm amazed how many errors
get through alls so it's always good to
spot them when you see them but it looks
to me like in Roman numerales 2 three
four and
five simply taking the word on or
out would address representative
Ames
question but when you get to the end of
five that's saying that the rate will be
1% for the period following
December 31st 2016 so this
doesn't uh end up at zero at the end of
26 perhaps there's some more language
27 so I I would again uh especially
given this and I appreciate uh the sharp
eyes on the committee pointing this out
um what I can say affirmatively is the
intent is for this tax to sunset on
December 31st
2026 I know there is also a repeal
provision in
hb2 um that removes the references to
this tax as well um there's I believe
you know several different sections that
are impacted with that so I did not
include that here in this document um
because again that really is a clerical
Amendment at that point but the
intent and to to represent a spilsbury's
point it might be as simple as removing
on or before and leaving the remaining
roaming NE rules as is or vice versa um
but the intent is that this t sunsets at
the end of
2026 um so again I I apologize for that
um and through the drafting process
we'll make sure that the the words do
match the intent
um that we've
disced if
um if R number one was true you
shouldn't see any
effect of the ENT in div tax in 2023 is
that
correct because you're going to keep it
at 5% up to the end
of
2023 so in
change there would be a fiscal impact
only for taxable periods in tax year
22 which based on the analysis from Dr
is 27% of what's applicable to that tax
year translates into that first fiscal
year so if you're
paying uh and I'm sorry I meant to say
tax year
23 um so there are impacts that would be
delayed it wouldn't be until fiscal
25 that all of the three primary tax
years that are paid over the course of a
given fiscal year would see that initial
reduction um and again I'm happy to uh
confer with Dr make sure that their
analysis matches the intent and that the
language follows that as well um and
again I think this again is a product of
working off a draft
I'm sure OS will have an email either
already in our inbox or in our inbox
before this is introduced um to make
sure that this language matches the
intent uh and I'm happy to to make sure
the committee has uh the most updated
language um either when hb2 is released
or um if we can Rectify that between now
and then happy to update this document
and res submit it okay representor
Brony this is uh questions really on the
broader
again forget about the reductions and
all that um indd have going up to 140. n
million in
2023 uh which is is quite a growth uh
but but so that means that after five
years at the minimal minimum the state's
gonna lose $140.9
million uh out you know four fiscal
years from now from
2023 so how does the governor plan to
make up that revenue or is it just that
we're going to reduce
expenses I understand the logic in
business taxes where in the business tax
you decrease the rate you you attract
more business and therefore and we've
we've kind of seen that
happen but with this one I'm not sure if
we'll have the same effect other than
like you said people moving here
and doing other taxable things I guess
uh and so just just go over the logic
because that's that's quite a whole
um$ 141 million dollar a
year so representative abami and I
appreciate the question and I I I think
that there are probably several
different layers um to to how exactly
the state uh would react once this tax
is phased out um certainly we will
continue to see revenue from other
sources increase in the intervening
years between where we are today and
fiscal year uh 26 27 and Beyond um what
I would also say is that dollars are
fungible they do continue to flow
throughout the economy so to your point
if you're not paying $10 in interest in
dividends tax for example you are
deploying those dollars in the economy
elsewhere um what that is to purchase
real estate invest in a business um or
you know even just do other taxable
things um so I don't want to give off
the impression that these tax dollars
should be a a one for one reduction
because we do see opportunity for people
uh to reinvest them in the New Hampshire
economy and um essentially see
offsetting tax increases elsewhere I
will comment that this budget does not
account for those but I do think that is
something um that the state is very
likely to see and experience as a result
of this um so I hope that answers your
question and I'm happy to um you know
dive into any one of those particular
areas if you'd like but um ultimately
this is something that the state would
have a five-year Glide path to evaluate
and consider um and given the the
strength of business taxes and other
taxes that the state levies were
confident that this would not um impact
critical State Services by by taking
this action certainly there's minimal
impact on on this bium from your
analysis here so okay I I'll let this
ask questions at this point thank
you that's a good point because let's
say
the we lose a100
million and that h100 million is
it goes into rooms and
meals but it will only come back to the
state that's taxable
at8 a half million so we essentially
lost 91 A5 million dolls it has to be
made up someplace
else no absolutely I I wouldn't say that
this would be a one for one impact but I
also don't know that these dollars
would drop off the table entirely right
if someone no longer is paying interest
in dividends and that gives them um the
economic capacity to start a business um
or grow an existing business right you
do see those benefits elsewhere in the
economy so will there be Revenue
reductions absolutely based on interest
and dividends right um and you do see a
proportion of those dollars come back to
the state in other
mechanisms um but I think again from a
policy standpoint as and that's where
this argument has its Genesis New
Hampshire is an income taxfree State um
this has been a ongoing conversation we
know there are a couple of different
proposals in the legislature to get from
point A to point B um and we
fundamentally believe this is the right
policy for the state to pursue um and
the revenue impacts would not be uh
insurmountable especially given the
length of the time Horizon and also this
budget proposing to delay it a year to
evaluate um the strength of the economy
postco um you know we do see opportunity
there um and hope that the legislature
uh will consider this proposal uh in the
way that you know really removes that
Aster from new hampsh being an interest
or a income taxfree
State when it was first talked about it
was a tax primarily affected the
elderly and if the elderly save $100
million is they're more or less going to
spend it on uh meals and rooms things
like that I doubt that many of them
business but anyway that's something to
think
about represent
El thank you Mr chairman on you're
talking about we can evaluate it the
first year since the Republicans started
putting prospective tax cuts into the
budgets I don't know if they ever did it
before uh about 10 years ago but since
they started doing that when you put it
in the budget it is almost impossible to
stop it if it is proving to be a
disaster and I am just wondering how
this goes together with fiscal
responsibility of this C of
State well thank you for the question
representative what I would say is that
we've we've looked to this budget we've
balanced it um based on this proposal uh
in 24 and 25 the same process would
would occur and in New Hampshire of
course the governor does have to present
a balance budget um I'm confident we
could do the same in 24 and 25 no matter
who happens to be in the corner office
at that point
um we don't see this as as ruinous for
the state by any means um yes there will
be fiscal impacts I don't believe that
they would be uh insurmountable or lead
to Draconian Cuts in state government or
state Services um and again we approach
this from the fundamental policy
prescription that this is the right
thing for New Hampshire to do um and and
that that that is the primary driver
behind why we are putting this forward
because fundamentally from a policy
standpoint this is something that I know
the legislature is is considering
proposals on we're excited to include it
in house bill to um and we do see a
pathway to get from five to zero over
the course of several years um in a way
overall any further questions on the
okay we've gone through the three major
questions to ask Bud
director do you have anything else need
to share with us Matthew
the only thing that I would would point
out uh Mr chairman would be the real
estate transfer tax uh and the tobacco
tax which you see here are the the two
uh rows at the bottom of this
spreadsheet um real estate transfer tax
has continued to have very robust
performance it is something that we know
is directly tied to the strength of the
housing market we know that the supply
is historically low for New Hampshire
homes um so at some point this ride will
come to an end the the question that I
know this committee is grappled with I
know the governor is grappled with and
odra is grappled with is what does that
Glide path look like um you see that we
are on the higher end of these ranges
Matt this is Chris can I just interrupt
for a second absolutely um you still
have the language up for the dividends
oh I'm sorry I uh sorry thank you for
that I had yep changed my screen on my
end but had not changed it in Zoom can
everyone see the charts now at this
point yes all right sorry about that um
even the young kids don't quite know how
to use all these different software
programs yet um but nonetheless um so as
you see here real estate transfer and
tobacco are the two rows at the bottom
of the spreadsheet or or this graph that
you see here and you'll notice that the
governor's estimate is on the higher end
of those r ranges we think in large part
the the offramp from this Hut housing
market will be more gradual um on a
average than others might have predicted
um and we've seen that both last month
where the monthly estimate that we had
used for for Rett um that we saw in the
February Revenue Focus um was surpassed
and um it's a question and it's
certainly something that's worth worth
of debate and I know the committee has
heard from people in this industry as
well um but I just wanted to explain the
reason why we were or what appears to be
a very bullish estimate for R um and
then the same with tobacco right we know
that um our Revenue tied to Tobacco is
heavily dependent on policies in other
states I know this committee has already
had conversations regarding that um but
what you'll notice is that our estimates
continue to slide down the range between
20 21 to 22 to
23 um so there there is a healthy degree
of um a conservative estimate for
tobacco um and I I just wanted to point
those two things out for the committee
questions uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for your presentation um my
constituents are mostly concerned about
downshifting as they see the different
articles in the news newspaper and um I
I feel like you did explain the policy
positions very well so I appreciate that
they're very worried about what how hb20
in some variation is going to fit into
all of this if there's going to be
suddenly you know this large extra cost
at the same time as we're making these
other cuts and uh um I did step out so
if I missed that I apologize but that's
the number one concern of our
constituents where I am thank you
representative Southworth and and could
you just remind me where your district
is uh do in do excellent uh beautiful
part of the state I might add House Bill
20 uh is the um education savings
account is that that Bill yes thank you
I I I focused on three numbers one two
and 25 and to clarify what their sense
is if we actually pay for many of the
$16,000 students already in private
schools plus add new ones they're you
know estimating 80 you know 100 million
uh at the same time as we're losing some
of the extra education funds we had in
the last budget so you know we have some
worried people sure and and happy to to
address those concerns and as far as the
revenue estimates go um what we project
to be in the education trust fund at the
end of this bium uh and this is included
in the executive summary as well slide
uh one
second uh slide
13 we see tremendous strength in that
education trust fund so we've assumed
that some students will return be uh in
fy22 and FY 23 coming out of Co um we
know some of them will continue their
either Alternative Learning model
whether it be private school or or
homeschool um so some of that is assumed
but even if the numbers are are greater
than what we see
um or what we've projected um there is
still strength in the education trust
fund based on the revenue estimates um I
would say if the the policy analysis of
of hb20 uh either for the committee or
or house finance as to whether or not um
that should be included in the budget or
not I understand there is a fiscal
impact but um we've kept those
conversations separate from what we've
put forward uh in house bill one and two
um and I'm sure that'll be a robust
debate over the next several months
thank you
followup all my followup is um for many
around the state they're looking to see
more funds in education and thinking
that better Revenue would provide more
funds to especially help the property
poor communities and it's hard for me to
connect that need with cutting the
taxes so and I appreciate the follow-up
question representative what I would say
is even with these tax cuts we will see
a historically strong balance in the
education trust fund um that includes
the $30 million in one-time Aid that
house bill 2 proposes uh to provide
through the public school infrastructure
fund um this is is such a tremendous
departure from where we were even four
years ago from from the days where the
education trust fund uh always closed
the bium with a negative balance and
there was a transfer from the general
fund um into the education trust fund
partially this is driven by fewer
students in the classroom because of
covid-19 and people choosing um to use
different educational models for this
year um but what I would say is that
these tax cuts do not jeopardize
education funding um and again I I point
you to slide 13 in the executive summary
the Surplus statements um the education
trust fund is is in a better place than
it really has ever been um since it took
effect two decades ago um and I think
that something that that speaks to the
strength um of the taxes that feed that
fund but also looking at the education
funding commission's report um this the
the the the solvency education trust
fund will allow the legislature to weigh
those
considerations um and identify if there
is a change in the formula we don't do
anything in the governor's budget that
that um necessarily responds to that the
one change the governor's proposed is
tied to how we calculate free and
reduced lunch um given the federal
government issued guidance removing the
paperwork requirement um which I think
was the right policy decision for the
federal government to take in lie of Co
um but the cascading impact for the
State education adequacy formula um
would have penalized in a way that uh we
certainly weren't uh interested in
continuing so that's why we've looked to
two preco uh levels to calculate that
portion of Education adequacy a in this
budget uh thank you and I think that
districts Senator
Brony yes uh Matt I'd like to talk about
two two taxes meil mail and rooms tax
and then the uh it's not on this on this
list here but the uh road toll if we can
because those two I feel and I think the
committee also feels are the two
toughest to predict because of uh
depending it's really dependent on the
quick those are really dependent on
covid uh in terms of of coming back but
then the other reality is will we ever
get a mov meals tax for instance will we
ever get has the model changed forever
in terms of businesses the way they act
um will there be as much business travel
as before or not uh you know uh will
more meetings continue with zoom and and
eliminating all that uh will people be
working for home longer uh continue to
work from home because businesses are
realizing that it seems to be working
okay so I just want to get a
sense uh from uh from you uh because
that all of that directly
impacts uh movement res tax if
businessmen aren't traveling there's no
there's no rooms there's no no meals and
there's no car
rentals uh and that all you know all
that and that Revenue that's generated
from that so I just want to know how
much of a discussion you had and in your
uh Circle there about this um I mean you
you're in the meal in rooms the plan in
two in 21 was uh call it 3 87 million
and you are projecting 363 so you're
you're you're projecting it's not coming
back uh all the way out to
2023 to former
levels but do do you agree or not agree
with the premise that maybe it will
never come back to the to the normal to
the norm but well I'll leave it at that
well I I really appreciate the question
representative abrami um and and thank
you I I don't know if I spoke to that
earlier that even though we're on the
high end of the meals and rooms tax
range we still don't see a return even
to fy19 levels um out through FY 2023
under current law so yes we're bullish
on the performance but the ranges are um
quite a bit more conservative than we
might see for the other ones so that
that's why we find ourselves on the
higher end of that but I do appreciate
the historical context going back to the
fiscal year 20 plan
uh as far
as long-term durable changes and travel
patterns I think a fundamentally it's
too early to tell um but I will give you
a better answer than that and say right
now a lot of this shift from working in
the office versus working from home has
been driven by the pandemic where people
are doing it for public health
reasons if businesses choose to make
these
changes durable and continue in a
flexible manner in an environment that
isn't constrained by a public health
emergency work from home really will
turn into this idea of a work from
anywhere model and I do think that some
of the impacts of maybe business travel
falling off and maybe that does take a
long time to come back I do think you'll
see people choose to relocate for a week
or month or a season to a different
state right and whether that is a rental
or if they're purchasing property I do
think that you will see those types of
impacts once we're out of Co and even if
you know we might not see the
traditional business travel some of
those impacts will have much different
um or some of those actions will have
much different impacts in a world um
that isn't you know hampered by a global
pandemic okay thank you uh Mr chair can
I ask another
question about the tobacco tax just a
comment
yes we we've been you know obviously we
benefited from the Massachusetts law
change last year about the menthol
cigarettes and all and we've researched
this um there are a couple of bills in
the hopper in Massachusetts now it's our
understanding that there's really it
doesn't seem like they're being acted
upon to resend that that policy about
mental
cigarettes um I think some members have
have figured out in Massachusetts that
they lost a lot of tax revenue from that
so um do have you had any of those
discussions right now it doesn't look
like anything's going to happen um but
but there are bills uh that are that are
out there in Massachusetts right now
were you aware of that and was that in
your discussion at all when it comes to
the cigarette tax thank you
representative and yes I would say that
we were generally aware of it um and and
worked with the Department of Revenue to
to calculate what the impacts might be
um under current law and obviously if
Massachusetts were to take that action
or if another state were to take an
action that was more favorable um I
think that contributes to some of the
uncertainty in that range for tobacco
tax but uh we're expecting decline of
one and a half% in
fy22 um from fy20 levels and you see
that we're more conservative uh where we
are in that range and then a reduction
of 3% in FY 23 uh and again moving even
below the median uh for FY 23 compared
to dr's range and um obviously those are
uncertainties that are unknowable at
this point in time I think your
characterization is is accurate that I
don't know that those bills will
ultimately get across the governor's
desk in
Massachusetts um but certainly something
to consider and the will have more
information than than we will have had
during the governor's phase uh to make
their analysis so your your reductions
are the normal um going back to the
normal reductions in the amount of
cigarette smoking that's actually going
on Nationwide correct that's correct
right so looking at people quitting or
or choosing other products that might
not be taxed or not taxed the same way
um where where they choose to to
purchase their products obviously this
is a very fluid
Marketplace that um everything within
historical levels for
sure reduction of 3% what historically
happening before the uh methol
cigarette further questions of uh
Matthew Mr chair U if no one else does
can we just touch on the uh Highway fund
for a minute on the
Roo uh hold on one
second we
have we we
can right after this discussion we're
going to be having the Implement on the
road to okay go ahead
uh maybe Matthew has something he can
contribute go ahead represent br oh no I
just wanted to
uh I'm looking at the she what's the
next item after we throw over the budget
director oh well I'm asking for the
governor uh for the uh the governor's uh
rationale between the for their
to I mean obviously it's coming back you
have it coming back but again uh not
back to the uh 21 plan you have a page
number uh representative it's uh well
maybe Chris Jay can put it up uh it's
it's the it's the document with the uh
the last P or the second page um Chris
sh could probably put it up yeah I can
share my screen if the committee wants
me to do that oh yeah Chris I'm happy to
let you share as well um this is the
underlying analysis that we use to get
to our Revenue estimate um but Chris why
don't I stop sharing this and let you
share your screen just at least for a
moment for the committee to them and
then and then um after I get done Matt
you can put that up
yeah I want to go far into this because
uh we're going to be discussing this
later go ahead so now you should be
seeing um the highway funds the
comparison document so here's the
governor's
now one thing that um we did do when we
put this together or I did do as we put
this together there's in fiscal year 22
there's a transfer of $8.1 million I
remove that number from any totals
because it's just a one-time transfer of
General funds um that would have
otherwise lapsed related to B uh Bridge
projects so these These are the
governor's estimates and if you want I
can pull up the work sheeet that has the
information from on the agency as well
as the um
uh the governor's information and the
right but what I saw from that Matt is
that you don't see the road toll or the
gasoline tax uh returning to 21 plan
23 um did I say that right
so I would have to look back at the
specific plan um I I I don't have that
right in front of me but certainly can
can pull it
um
worksheet yes I I do see that Chris and
so looking
at official plan of 27 for fy20 yes so
represented that that would be accurate
um we aren't even projecting to to get
back to that level by FY
23 when you look at the 2020 plan a more
conservative estimate then right which I
say I would kind of concur with actually
that
it's that's going to take a while to
come back as
well amount of Miles travel by people
especially again it also was tied to
people not commuting either um if the
model changes where more people work
from home and it continues that way
after Co it will also be affected as
each year Goes On by the efficiency of
Vehicles you have anything else to say
on that Master sure I'm happy just to
talk through the methodology briefly and
I know we are coming up on 11 um but um
Matt do you want me to stop sharing so
you can your document up or do you want
me to just leave what I have here if you
could Chris I'm happy to to show the
committee uh briefly what what our
analysis looked like and and why it is a
little bit different than the department
of safety um I will say we we are right
in line with Department of Safety on all
the other estimates relative to uh motor
vehicle fees or fines or or any other
source of Revenue um but when it comes
to the highway fund what we what our
methodology was was to look at ual data
um and we've noticed that there's been a
fairly consistent 1% growth
rate rather than try to estimate how
strong the recovery would be we looked
at it and projected out to where we
would have been based on historical
Trends in fy21 22 and 23 without Co
right so applying a 1% growth factor
each
year and then reducing the impact
uh by a factor of 92% to get to our
Revenue estimate essentially saying that
we look at the Historical
growth um and then
determine based on variety of data um
how many fewer miles people would drive
and how much more efficient vehicles
would be um I would say that well this
budget does
Infuse um Federal relief money for
highways or um lapses from House Bill
um the long-term structural
challenges um do still remain um so
these were one-time injections in light
of Co um but this postco recovery um is
how we chose to get to our numbers uh as
a
result I'm sure the department of safety
will have some more information there as
well later today great we don't have a
copy of this
right you do not that's Matt's document
and I'm happy to to clean that up and
share it for the committee as well um in
a more presentable
used represent
El thank you could you let us know what
um on how you picked the 8% loss that
you
did sure so we and this is an estimate
of course the same way a lot of other
things are um but we looked at uh
traffic patterns and Mobility analyses
um based on for example data that Google
collects on different types of activity
uh people commuting to work people going
to the grocery store uh travel patterns
um and we do think that covid will will
continue to dampen that um based on some
of the trends that representative abami
mentioned earlier um so again the only
difference in our methodology is
compared to the Department of Safety we
continued that historical growth pattern
and then reduced based on an impact of
covid where the department looked at
where we were in fiscal 20 and fiscal 21
uh and then
extrapolated uh what would come back um
in a non-co world for 22 and 23 I think
both methodologies are equally as valid
um I know that those do produce slightly
different numbers based on uh where the
the final Revenue projections came out
um but again just two different ways to
look at a very complex problem that um
even the best experts uh don't fully
have their hands around just
yet thank you that sounds better
questions hey the timing is very
good happy to help uh Mr
chairman excellent
um if there's no further questions of
Matthew thank you very much that's been
very informative and you'll provide
committee with copies of the
highway all right Absolutely I'll work
with Chris to make sure that any of the
materials that I showed today do make it
to the full committee um as PDF copies
as well okay we're going to check a five
section
you
e
for
yes do we have the members from the
highway
department yes represent major they're
in the call you have Scott Brier from
the road toll um
Administration and um Steve LaVoy who's
great and they're both on the call ready
right I thought having the
uh him work so closely in Chris J so we
had so many documents in front of us was
enormously
helpful the sharing in the
screen really makes it really I it it it
makes being on Zoom all the time really
I mean that's the counterveiling
uh part of it is that having
those documents in front of us
simultaneously so very very helpful on
budgets might as well fig this type of
virtual meeting if we didn't weren't
able to work with the documents right it
really
uh very very helpful I know that um
takes a lot of time for the people doing
the presentations and for our
committee's uh staff people but it's
very very helpful I wanted to thank uh
chisay for his efforts oh good we're
right on time now so Steve Lavoy and
Scott Brer are going to go over their
estimates for road toll miscellanous
highway uh good morning Mr chair members
of the committee Steve Lavoy director of
administration from the Department of
Safety and as you mentioned Scott Brier
is with me today um so we were um um I
can share my screen uh we were told that
we'd be focusing exclusively on the road
toll and so I thought what we might do
is um just revisit the road toll
sections of the presentation that we
Prov provided um about a week and a half
ago um and then open it up for any
questions at that point um we were on
during the governor's budget director's
presentation so um um I expect we'll be
able to talk through some of the
differences that we have between our our
estimates um so if that works uh Mr
chair I I'll share my my screen now
right
all
so our road to toll Revenue um
projections as you as you can see this
shows
the the revenues that were collected the
actuals from fy16 through fy20 and fy20
had a significant decline um and that
was due to covid our fy21 projection uh
is we're projecting to fall even further
to 114
three
million um and then we are projecting an
an increase um starting to recover but
we're projecting that recovery to be
relatively slow um we're projecting for
fy22 uh to collect
12.2 million and for 23 to collect
121.5 million I me as you can see that
amount is still less than what we
collected in
fy19 um but we do think once we start um
returning to whatever this new normal
volume is that we'll start seeing those
um slight increases we were we were
seeing uh increases of about 1% every
year up until covid hit um now keep in
mind that 1% increase in the in the uh
the highway fund that Revenue increase
does not correspond to um or or cover
the increases in expenditures that this
fund supports at both do and the
department of safety so that's what we
keep talking about the structural
deficit that we have in the highway fund
um that that we continue to to struggle
with moving forward um but that being
said we we were able to make um Mak ends
meet for the most part through through a
lot of um cost-saving measures that
occurred both here and at dot um but
from a revenue perspective we're not
close to recovering our fy19 based on
our estimates the next slide really
shows where our assumptions come from
and this shows the decline in um
year-over-year Revenue collection um on
a monthly basis and what you see here is
at the start of the pandemic um we would
have some minor fluctuations monthly we
might be down 2% one month we might be
up 2% the other month and that's what
you're seeing here in January and
February um in fact we were flat in uh
heading into March but then when Co hit
um significant decline so at its worst
we were 36% less U year-over-year
monthly um uh throughout this this
period but then you'll see we had a
steep increase in the summer months so
that's corresponding to our our May
through our September even into October
period and that had to do with a lot of
individuals who because of travel
restrictions they weren't uh they
weren't vacationing out of state they
weren't flying um for for travel outside
of New England we had a lot of um of of
of Massachusetts New England related
people coming into the state hiking
using our natural resources and so we
see we we really believe most of this
recovery is due to the travel and
tourism in the summer months uh because
then what you see is in the fall once
the good hiking season uh disappeared
people weren't on the Lakes you see a
decline um uh that that happens again
now this also corresponds to you know
what we call the second wave when there
were additional infections as well and
so you're seeing how Co is really
driving the um uh the driving habits of
of of our um residents and our visitors
So based on our original estimates we
were looking at at really looking at the
information from the summer um we felt
that we would be landing at we would be
landing around the maybe 5% range so
when we would recover we weren't
expecting to recover more than 5% of our
fy19 our preco revenues and that that's
what our new Baseline would be uh then
with the second surge that came forward
and kind of some additional analysis we
didn't feel comfortable that 5% was the
right number and we brought that down
even farther and so as you can see we're
projecting out to end fiscal year 21 um
in June at 8% monthly less than
fy19 we then took that figure and just
carried that forward for fy22 and FY 23
just assuming that we would have an 8%
decline for 22 and then that would
increase with our 1% annual increase
that we've seen in the past to a 7%
decline from um fy19 amounts uh in FY 23
so that's where how we developed our um
20 million uh dollar estimate for 22 and
our $121 million estimate for for
23 um as as as Matt Meo mentioned um the
governor's approach was a little bit
different so so they um they took an
approach looking at what would we have
been if the pandemic had not existed if
we didn't have the covid reductions and
then worked on their worked their
estimate back down from there using
assumptions related to um what would the
economic um recovery look like where
would that land so uh their their
projections are are are higher than ours
um but still well within the range of of
reasonableness as far as we're concerned
it's really just a different approach
and a different way to look at um that
those variables that
unfortunately we don't really have any
good information on so we're we're
trying to apply our judgment and our
best information that we have to come up
with what type of traffic volume can we
expect in 22 and 23 um and uh that's
that's really what what the discussion
Point um around our numbers needs to be
around um and so with that I think um
we'll be happy to open it up for any
questions that um that the committee
might
have in the these
graphs and the hand out we received from
the Department of Safety when they came
in to tell talk about their
revenue
history and that was
January questions from the committee
representative
Bry thank you Mr chair U thank you for
your presentation um there's normal
seasonality correct um and is in the
packet I can't recall is there a chart
of a normal normal Peaks and valleys be
by month uh without covid you know March
would probably be less than uh July you
know what I mean yeah we didn't we
didn't show the normal um fluctuations
um compared to the covid
amounts okay but you do have t you do
have charts to that effect Alo right
somewhere yes we have we have the data
we could we could prepare that okay
thank
you fine if you send that to us it be
repres oh I didn't hear you say my
name sorry um I'm having a lot of
trouble seeing these screens their their
charts are too small and the charts of
the budget director were too bright uh
but on I did want to ask uh Mr Lavoy if
they if the governor it sounded like the
governor's budget director got a hold of
surveys of uh how much traffic on was
generated by going to the grocer restore
versus commuting versus other things on
and use that to reach his 8% reduction
and I'm wondering if he shared those
charts with you or because I know that
you were operating partly on the idea
okay there's going to be less commuting
there's going to um be maybe more local
trips so thank
you yeah um I I did not see any of any
of the specific data that that he
utilized um I did have some discussions
with him and anecdotally kind of had
those discussions um to see what are you
seeing what information um how does that
influence where where you're headed
versus how is it influencing where where
we are with our so we did have some
discussions but I didn't see the uh the
projections
represent okay thank you
um so this is a question about uh moving
towards more efficient vehicles and uh
electric cars
electric uh driven cars whatever the
right word is um and uh the movement in
that direction I know I know you've been
wrestling with this over time and trying
to guesstimate estimate uh the decline
in in Road toe Revenue because of this
um and and so I'd like you to update us
on
how how that factors in um as you do
your estimating I think the governor's
budget director mentioned this this uh
variable but didn't go into it and uh
I'd like to know what you're you're
you're doing with this sure
so like you mentioned the challenge is
determining predict
what the future impact will be um
because obviously we don't want to
underestimate and and um result in in
reductions to state budget expenditures
but we also don't want to overestimate
and fund programs that we can't follow
through with in the next several years
so the challenge that we've faced is we
don't really have any good data as far
as adoption rates how many people are
intending to move to electron electric
vehicles um from internal combustion we
we have there there's National Data and
there's a lot of adoption in certain
parts of the country um where where you
where you see a transition occurring um
we don't have as as much as robust
adoption here in New Hampshire and
there's several reasons that we've
identified as to why that might be um
One is because we're a rural State and
many of us um who don't live directly
within one of the major cities have we
have to travel um to get through the
grocery store to get to basic services
in our towns and our communities and so
the idea of range anxiety how far will
my battery last before I need to
recharge I think it I think it it means
more here in New Hampshire than maybe in
some other areas um that are more urban
that are more developed um we also well
the electric infrastructure is building
um it is being created it's it's not
there yet um so that's another pie that
adds to that if I can charge my vehicle
at home however how far can I go can I
do I have enough charge to if I live in
the Southern Tier if I live in NASA can
I drive up to Lon mountain and back on a
single charge can I drive up to
Burlington Vermont and back on a single
charge um if not where can I stop and
charge my vehicle so those those that
infrastructure hasn't been fully
developed yet and still has a long ways
to go
um in the state there's been mentions in
the paper in the in the Press recently
of some areas um you know some companies
adopting plans to CH to transition their
Fleet to electric vehicles I think
that's where we're going to see the
biggest um the biggest impact on our
road toll is when fleets start moving
because that's really G to um have a
have a large impact quickly um even if
the public adoption is slower
um if if fleet vehicles start going
electric then we're going to see a
significant decline in uh gasoline usage
but even even with those announcements
most of those are talking about
2035 um there it's it's several years
out maybe maybe by 2030 they'll have a
fully electric Fleet so taking all of
that uncertainty and um we we decided
that we didn't have enough information
to pin a number or a percentage and say
this amount is going to decline by for
because of road toll uh because of
electric vehicles so instead we looked
backwards and said well we've seen a 1%
increase over the last several years
excluding covid excluding 20 and 21 and
we're assuming that the rate of adoption
will continue at those levels the early
adopters have adopted and will likely
continue to buy electric vehicles there
will be some increase in the public but
we're not expecting a SE change in the
next two years in the next five years
there it's likely a different story so
in the next five years we're going to
have to keep looking at this and see
where we'll be in the next next Bion but
for now that that was what our approach
was we've already built that into our
estimate by looking at our previous um
actual Collections and using that figure
and carrying that forward that 1%
increase flag path forward into the
future
years I think that's a very good
to
sorry uh the Volkswagen settlement was
supposed to be partially spent on
electric charging stations were they
ever
buil that was a state yeah I believe
that is with the office of strategic
initiatives um I believe they handled
the Volkswagen settlement funding um I I
had heard that I know that there were
plans being developed but I don't know
what the status of that project was
thank you
Steve yes um I believe uh I believe that
there was a bill introduced that's uh
pending in committee to deal with that
um
but I don't know what the status of that
bill is but I do I am aware there is
legislation to look at that but the
money hasn't been uh that has not been
time thank
you
Murphy uh thank you Mr chairman uh my
question is a general one but also
involves Department of um safety in the
toll tax so much of these uh Revenue
estimates seem to be
relatively straightforward but there are
a few that are very very covid sensitive
so meals in room and tolls and travel
Etc and my question is do you or other
agency leaders have direct conversations
with folks like Dr Chan or others to get
a an inside look as to what their
thoughts are and predictions relative
to um these predictions that we're
making such as you know vaccine
availability variant Etc I'm just
wondering if you have had any direct
conversations with those in the medical
community to help with your um your
predictions um thank you for the
question I haven't had any direct
conversations myself um I have been
following the vaccine distribution plan
the roll out um I I I think that there's
been a lot of good the public
information that's been made available
Dr Chan press conferences um so so I
have been following that progress and
that's absolutely part of our our
consideration but we haven't had any any
specific discussions about how would
that pertain to our um our our road toll
projections we've just utilized the
publicly available information as part
of our assessment okay thank you and let
me follow up on that um repr
Murphy this afternoon I should be
getting the telephone number the
commissioner of
HHS because Chris has been trying to get
somebody from HHS to come and talk to us
about about this and we haven't been
having any luck so right that was the
reason I ask the question is that we've
been making predictions it seems heavily
Laden with the covid overlap and without
a lot of real direction from them so
that'll be helpful so I'll be going
directly to the Comm Commissioner of
HHS um representative
set thank you Mr chairman just a kind of
a question slash comment uh Mr Lavoy
stated that um their uh Fleet company
fleets that are planning on being all
electric by a date certain uh the date
of uh 2035 has been thrown around but
more importantly there are manufacturers
like GM who have said that they're uh
their product lines are going to be all
electric now I don't suspect that um
they're going to flip a switch in 2035
and we're going to be uh buying all
electric vehicles I believe there's
going to be a transitional period And
this is an issue that maybe should be uh
we should address a little more
proactively um because it it will affect
I'd rather uh be thinking ahead of the
uh curve here on this one uh because
that's the reality we're going to be
seeing more of these vehicles as the uh
months and years go by it's going to
step up quickly I
think and it isn't just electric
vehicles it's hybrid vehicles and high
efficiency gasoline vehicles they're all
getting better each year and I think it
was just uh Ford and general mortors
that come out said that by 1930 I guess
they're going to be switching over to
electric vehicles that's not too far
that further questions of uh Steve
Lavoy if not and Scott
Brier do you have any um bring us up to
do you have anything else to oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry Mr chairman um I
basically um agree with what's been
stated by Steve um I think that our our
numbers are uh we looked at one way
arriving at our numbers and uh the
governor's office looked at another uh
both those uh both those variables are
reasonable it's just like the approach
that each each of us choose to arrive at
our numbers but like right now um I
wouldn't change any of uh I mean I think
both methodologies are reasonable but I
would stick with uh the numbers that we
have
that's study done last
year paid for by the federal government
I think was about
$250,000 to look
at uh the road
to as part of it uh yeah vehicle became
more efficient have
you been making use of this
study um some of the comments that Steve
made like for example uh where we live
like we're not uh some of the states
have obviously have more urban areas uh
New Hampshire I mean if you look at
Portsmouth uh in Nashville and
Manchester they they do have electric
charging stations and so forth but the
whole issue is until you get an
infrastructure for example that runs up
the whole length of the interstate up 93
and 89 I think that the electric cars in
our state are going to be very limited
until that infrastructure is built and
based on the data that I've seen I I
think we're at least four five at least
five years away from having the
infrastructure that would really affect
us switching over to uh alternative fuel
source such as electric and I think that
uh the gasoline and Diesel's here for at
least five more years and I don't think
there's going to be any significant
impacts uh other than uh yeah I mean to
be minimal but I don't see any
significant impacts that would affect
our Revenue estimates okay this study
was done for New
Hampshire and the report is out and I
was
wondering did that
report have any information that helps
you in
be I I think um I I didn't think there
was enough in there to use for
projections I think it was a more kind
of um I Steve you want to comment on
that a little but I I didn't think it
would really gave us anything specific
that we could say this is how it's going
to affect Road
pool yeah so that that that report is um
is extremely useful it's I know it's
posted on the dot website and it was
really designed to take a look at
vehicle mileage use um and and what that
would look like with um moving forward
if there were a um a change in our in
our fee structure so that there were
some underlying assumptions that were
used um to develop their estimates and
we've looked at those
um we haven't
directly uh uh applied them in our
analysis but we've looked at that report
and and we revisit that to help
influence our the decisions that we make
related to our um our our estimates and
the variables that we're focused on um
but that that analysis was specifically
looking at a
um um a road usage fee uh and how much
uh of that would would be required to
offset the loss in Revenue um based on
again they're using certain assumptions
related to the adoption of electric
vehicles replacing internal combustion
engines gasoline engines so um so yes we
have it we've looked at it but it's not
directly a plug-and playay type of a of
of an
analysis thank
you anything else that you uh want to
share with the committee any questions
from the committee on the road
to I I don't have anything else to share
but you know I'll take questions if
anybody has
questions 10 none ready up thank you
very
much thank you thank you and for the
committee those graphs are in the
document we were given on January 27th
when they came came in and did the
highway
Pro Chris do we have anything else
morning uh you do
not okay that was the only thing um
after the governor's budget director was
to have Steve and Scott talk to you
toll so next
Tuesday we'll be meeting to do uh
Revenue
estimates so in between now and next
Tuesday you want to look at these you
Susan you'll probably have a uh Caucus
meeting with your
caucus and I'll try to have a Caucus
when we get together on Tuesday we hope
to be able to finalize a graph numbers
for our Revenue estimates so we can have
these available to
either give them to the finance
chairman or do a house
resolution before the Full House on the
25th and we'll make that
decision depending on how well we do on
estimat Mr chairman so we're not going
to have any uh opportunity together
until Tuesday to
um take a first stab at
numbers um
no this is
Thursday uh
either caucuses or or other
then we may we may want to have a caucus
or would you want to have a a separate
work session on Monday it's it's
actually it's not advertised in the
calendar so we will do a work session on
all day Tuesday we'll have the Dr and
other agency heads there so we can
necessary so do your homework
now and Tuesday and be prepared to come
your estimates for each every one of
these Revenue estimates and then we'll
discuss it and then we'll take a
vote question could I just then ask um
the Democrats if um I assumed we were
going all day if uh at least some of
them could come together this afternoon
to work on this because we only have an
hour and a half on Saturday we have to
afternoon I have to do early afternoon I
have a 2:30 hard
stop I also have
2:30 I can be the early afternoon
to okay so I
cannot I I have an elderly friend that
fell yesterday in um herb out person and
I've been yeah so she might have surgery
this afternoon need my approval and yeah
well could I just ask uh the Democrats
that can to come at come at 12:30 to our
caucus
room and um we'll try to go through to
2:30 and see what we can can talk about
because we've got a number of new people
they haven't been through this before
thank you we send out Zoom or some
connection on it would be Amanda Amanda
can you do that yep I'll resend it it's
the same link we've been using but I'll
resend
it okay let me ask the
Republicans
um who could you be available at 3 o'
this
afternoon or 10:00 tomorrow
morning 3:00 this afternoon with would
be better for me uh chairman major this
is hersel okay and I would agree with
that this afternoon would be better I
mean it's snowing out already so what
the heck a heck yeah I can do either so
I'm not available Friday but today would
be great would be better good I'll send
you out a link for three o'clock this
afternoon for
caucus represent major can I uh s um out
the idea that we two last term last ter
when we did this I think and Susan uh
correct me if I'm wrong didn't didn't
the Republicans and not to make this a
partisan thing because it isn't it
really isn't I I think when we come up
with our estimates there's 24 of us so
we're gonna we're gonna go through Pat
what do you think you know you know
Allan what do you think you know you
know what we did last time is that we we
we got we went through that process with
our caucus and we we came up with a
republican number and then the Democrats
came up with a Democrat number so that
when we we sat down with business taxes
that we we had two numbers that we were
working with and then we we kind of
talked about why we came up with our our
number versus having 24 numbers now we
could all all throw in a number and
divide by
24 that's fine with me I'm just trying
to understand what the methodology is
going to be we had a r
uh if if yeah if I could just
eventually yeah if I could just uh
clarify on our side at least on when we
did that um we had a number but then we
had a couple of people on either ends of
talk as I recall um that so it wasn't
wasn't we had ranges if I remember no
that was the summer I'm thinking of the
summer
sorry we're going to have essentially
the same thing do those in our
individual caucuses and then we'll get
together right and we did listen to each
other as I recall at least a lot once we
got together and people had individual
things that they threw in but we started
as you said from right
from numbers that we would work our way
off of or
onto and just make it a little more
efficient on
Tuesday instead of having 24 different
opinions uh we'll never get to the end
um so I mean we could just say you know
what do you think and we could divide by
24 no one extreme but we've never done
it that way it's basically whoever
speaks up um you know we want everybody
to speak up too so it's still easy to do
that in your caucus um and then come the
consensus there when we meet on Tuesday
I'll ask let's say there's two or three
they talking fine let them talk we'll
cut it off and then go through each and
every
one and where do you land on this and
why well we have like seven or eight
revenue streams left
and that's that'll be three votes on
each one of them um right I mean that's
this year the next two years uh Revenue
estimates so we got a bit of work to do
we we dealt with all the easy ones these
are the more difficult
ones um that's why we need to start it
right now and be ready for Tuesday right
and our estimates are on the law
today yeah
our our estimates don't take into
account I just thought you want to
remind people of that if we come out on
Tuesday uh we can't agree on a number
that's fine what we'll
do depends on which ones
it it's a
major your stream or not then we will
split it and probably won't come out
with a resolution it'll be a draft
committee once we agree on a number then
way so that's
why we're not going to make that final
decision on a resolution until we see
Tuesday because the finance committee
working no my hands I'm lowering my
hand any questions F questions yeah just
uh Susan what time do you want to start
this afternoon
well I said 12:30 assuming that we were
going to quit at 11:30 but it's now
quarter 12 so maybe quarter to
one okay that's fine unless
you
no okay if there's no questions then our
individual CL will be meeting and then
Tuesday you may uh we may end up meeting
Monday also as a
cice
okay all right well thank you Norm
you're gonna get a you're gonna get a uh
a link out for us right a link out right
now okay thank